[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
JASON KU: Welcome, everybody,
to our lecture 14 of 6.006.
This is our last lecture
on graph algorithms,
in particular, the
last lecture we'll have
on weighted shortest paths.
But we're going to talk about
a slightly different problem
today, different than single
source shortest paths.
We're going to be talking
about all-pairs shortest paths.
But first, let's review
our single source
shortest paths algorithms.
We had BFS, DAG
relaxation, Dijkstra,
which we saw last time, which
gets pretty close to linear.
V log V plus E is
pretty close to linear.
It's much closer to linear than
the general algorithm we have
for solving single
source shortest paths,
namely, Bellman-Ford, which is a
little bit more like quadratic.
This is like the
difference between--
for sparse graphs, this is like
the difference between sorting,
using insertion sort and
n squared, and merge sort
in N log N, for example.
We're going to get
actually quite a big bonus
for large input sizes by
using Dijkstra when we can.
Today, we're going
to be focusing
on this new problem called
all-pairs shortest paths.
It's not really complicated.
Instead of having
a single source,
we are essentially wanting
to, given an input--
this is our weighted graph,
where we've got a graph V, E,
and we've got a weight function
from the edges to the integers.
This is our general
weighted graph.
We want our output
to be something
like, the shortest
path distance from u
to v for every u and
v in our vortex set.
That's what we want to return.
Now, there's one
caveat here that,
if there's a negative
weight cycle in our graph--
in other words, if any of these
delta u, v's is minus infinity,
there's a negative rate
cycle in our graph.
So unless, I guess--
or abort if G contains
a negative weight cycle.
So we're not actually going
to worry about negative weight
cycles in today's class.
If we have a graph, it
could have negative weights.
These are any integers.
It could include
negative weight edges.
But as long as all
of our path distances
are bounded from
below, none of them
are negative infinity, we
don't have any negative weight
cycles, then I want you to
output all of these shortest
path distances.
Now, in particular,
this output could--
any of these outputs needs to
have size theta of V squared.
Because for every
pair of vertices,
I need to return to you
a number, or infinity,
or minus infinity or
something like that.
But we are not dealing with
a case with minus infinity.
The output could have size--
this is a theta here.
It does have size V squared.
But in particular,
it's at least V
squared because I
need to give a number
for each pair of vertices.
And so we couldn't
hope for linear time
in the size of this graph
for this problem, right?
Single source shortest
paths, for certain versions
of the problem, we
need to read the graph.
And so we need to
use linear time.
But in this problem, our
output has quadratic size
in the number of vertices.
So in a sense, we can't
do better than this.
We can't do better
than quadratic.
And actually, what's
one way we could
solve all-pairs shortest
paths by using stuff
we've already done
in this class?
That's why I put
this slide up here.
Yeah, we could just
solve a single source
shortest paths algorithm from
every vertex in my graph.
That seems like a
stupid thing to do.
It's almost brute
force on the vertices.
But it's certainly a way we
could solve this problem,
in polynomial time.
And we could definitely
solve it in order
V squared E time,
using Bellman-Ford.
We just take V steps of
Bellman-Ford and deal
with a graph on any
set of vertices.
We can do better than this.
We can do better
than this for graphs
that are special in some way.
We can do V times V
plus E, V times linear.
If our weights are
positive and bounded,
we can use BFS V times.
Or if our graph
doesn't have cycles,
we could use DAG
relaxation V times.
Or if our graph had non-negative
edge weights, we could get,
basically, V squared
log V plus V times E.
And that's actually not bad.
In sparse graphs, this is what
Bellman-Ford would give us.
But if we had Dijkstra's,
for example, if we
had all positive edge weights--
or non-negative, sorry,
we could get V squared
log V plus V, E time.
This is V times Dijkstra.
OK, so how do these
running times compare?
This is V times Bellman-Ford.
This is V times Dijkstra.
Let's just get a feel
for this separation here.
If we had a sparse graph
where V is upper-bounded
by the number of vertices, this
one looks like V squared log V.
This one looks like V cubed.
And we need to spend at
least V squared time.
So actually, this
is really close
to linear in the
size of the graph,
just off by a log factor, just
like sorting would entail.
And this one would
have a linear factor.
In the sparse graph, this
would be a linear factor worse
than this, instead of
a logarithmic factor--
again, this linear
to log separation.
We don't want to have to
do this running time if we
don't have to.
That's the name of the game.
And really, all we're
going to do in this lecture
is try to solve how we can
make this running time faster
by doing something a
little bit more intelligent
than running a single
source shortest path
algorithm from every vertex.
How are we going to do that?
Well, we could-- let's see.
What are we doing?
Right.
The idea here, if
we had a graph--
should my graph be
directed or undirected?
I'm not sure.
Let's see if we can
make a directed graph.
OK, so here's a directed graph.
Why do I not care about
undirected graphs?
Can anyone tell me?
Yeah, it's because--
I don't care about
undirected graphs
because, if I had
an undirected graph,
I could detect whether
I had negative weight
cycles in constant time--
I'm sorry, in linear time.
I could just check each edge,
see if it has negative weight,
because a negative weight
edge, an undirected edge
is a cycle of negative weight.
So I could just-- if it has
any negative edge weights,
I could return in linear time
that it does, and I can abort.
Or it has only positive weights,
and I can still use Dijkstra.
So that's all good.
So we're only concerned about
needing to run Bellman-Ford
on directed graphs that
potentially have negative edge
weight.
OK, so here's a graph.
Let's see.
Is this a graph that I want?
Sure.
Let's say we've got that
direction and this direction.
Say we have a directed
graph like this.
And let's say this is s.
This is our source.
And we have weights being 2--
sorry, weights being
4, 1, 1, 2, 2, 2, 2.
So this is an
example of a graph we
might want to run all-pairs
shortest paths on.
Maybe we also have negative
weights in this graph.
In particular, this has
a negative weight cycle.
I don't want negative
weight cycles,
so I'm going to make this 0.
So this graph doesn't have
negative weight cycles.
Great.
That's true, great.
All right, so here's an
example that we might want
to compute shortest paths on.
There's no s in
all-pairs shortest paths.
But I'm going to be
talking about a couple
of shortest paths from
s in my next argument,
so I'm just labeling
that vertex as s.
OK, the claim-- the
approach we're going to do,
we're going to try to take a
graph that has negative edge
weights, directed graph.
We don't know if it has
negative cycles or not yet.
But we want to compute
all-pairs shortest paths,
not in this running time,
but in this running time.
How could we do that?
Well, maybe it's
possible that we
can change the
weight of every edge
so that they're all
positive, but shortest paths
are preserved.
So basically, if a
particular path--
like OK, the shortest path
from s to t here is 1, 2, 3.
I could change edge
weights in this graph.
Say, for example, if
I changed 1 to 0 here,
that would still make
this a shortest path.
I haven't done-- I've
reweighted the graph.
Shortest paths have to be
the same in this graph.
But now-- sorry.
Yeah, this is not
a shortest path.
OK, I'll make that minus
2, and then these both 2,
and I think this 4.
Man, I really should have
done my example beforehand.
OK, so this still doesn't
have negative weight cycles.
It has a negative weight edge.
But this path is
longer than this path.
So when this was
1, this had length
of 3, which was
shorter than this path.
That is length 4.
OK, cool.
So this is the shortest
path from s to t.
I could change
weights in this graph,
for example, changing
2 to 3 and 1 to 0.
That changed
weights in my graph,
but shortest paths
remain the same.
So maybe there's a way I
could reweight my edges so
that shortest paths
stay the same,
shortest paths are preserved.
So I'm going to put this
back to where it was.
So idea-- make edge
weights non-negative while
preserving shortest paths.
In other words, just
reweight the edges
here so that
shortest paths in G--
this is G-- after we reweight
will go to some graph G prime,
with the same combinatorial
structure just different edge
weights.
And we want shortest paths--
we want these weights
to all be non-negative.
And we want shortest paths, if
there's a shortest path in G,
it continues to be a shortest
path in the reweighted graph.
That's the goal for today.
If we can do that transformation
and this is not negative,
then we're done.
We're done because we
can just run Dijkstra V
times on that new graph, get
the shortest path distances,
construct a shortest path
tree from those distances,
and then traverse that
tree in the original graph,
and compute shortest
paths along that tree.
So that's the claim.
Claim-- we can compute
distances in G--
so we're going to
restrict G prime to have
with non-negative edge weights.
If we have such a G prime with
non-negative edge weights,
we can compute distances
in G from distances
in G prime in V times V
plus E, which is smaller
than our Dijkstra running time.
This is our Dijkstra
running time.
And this is smaller than that.
So that would be fine, right?
What do we do?
We have our new graph G prime.
It has all positive
edge weights,
so we run all-pairs
shortest paths in here
by just running
Dijkstra V times.
And then for each vertex s, we
have some shortest path tree
to all the things that
it's connected to.
We can look at that
path in G. This
is the same common
[INAUDIBLE] graph, just
with different edge weights.
We can look at that same tree.
I'm not going to be able to
draw the exact same tree here.
But what I can do is I can just
BFS or DFS along this tree.
And every time I have an edge,
because each one of these
is the shortest
path in this tree,
I can just compute every
time I traverse an edge what
its shortest path
distance is in G
in linear time for that
vertex for that particular s.
I do that over all s's, and
I get this running time.
So that's the goal here.
All right, so we
first wanted to find--
we were wanting to
make edge weights
non-negative while
preserving shortest paths.
Because if we could
do that, we could
solve our original all-pairs
shortest paths problem.
So this is the proof sketch.
But how can we do this?
But how?
It doesn't even seem like this
could be possible, generally.
How can I just
reweight the edges
and maintain that the shortest
path trees are the same?
That seems hard to do.
And in particular, if
there's a negative weight
cycle in this graph,
it's impossible to do.
So claim-- not possible if
G contains a negative weight
cycle.
OK, the exclamation point
is just my comment here.
So if G contains a
negative weight cycle,
then in particular, the shortest
path distance or a shortest
path in G--
if this is G, say we
have a negative weight
cycle directed cycle C here.
In particular, the shortest
path from this vertex
on the cycle to this
vertex on the cycle,
what is its shortest path?
It's infinite.
A shortest path is
infinite around this cycle.
You just keep going around
the cycle over and over
and over again because
it has a negative weight.
Weight of C is less
than 0, strictly.
That's what a negative
weight cycle is.
OK, so the shortest path--
a shortest path from s to t
has infinite length and, in
particular, is non-simple.
However-- so shortest path
from s to t is non-simple.
But as we proved in
the last lecture,
shortest paths in a graph with
non-negative weights are what?
Are simple, right?
Because they're just
shortest path trees.
So that's a contradiction.
So this is not possible.
So given a graph with negative
weights but no negative cycle,
it's still not clear how we
could find such a reweighting
of the graph.
Can we do this?
Well, we're going to
exploit a little idea here.
How can we transform
the weights of a path?
Well, how-- what's a--
a silly idea, I have
this silly idea.
If I don't want negative
edge weights in this graph--
ugh, this is messy in the back.
You got edge weights 1,
minus 2, 0, 1, 4, 5, and 1.
There's only one negative
edge weight here.
What if I just added
a large number,
or in particular, the
negative of the smallest
edge in my graph to
every edge in my graph?
Then I'll have a graph
with non-negative weights.
Fantastic.
Why is that not a good idea?
Well, in particular, if
I did that to this graph,
if I added 2 to every edge,
the weight of this path,
which was the shortest
path, changed from weight 3
to weight 9, because I
added 2 for every edge.
But this path, which wasn't a
shortest path in the original
graph-- it had weight 4--
increased only by 2.
Now that is a shortest path.
Or it's a shorter
path than this one,
so this one can't
be a shortest path.
So that transformation,
sure, would
make all the weights
non-negative,
but would not preserve
shortest paths.
In particular, if I added the
same edge weight to every edge,
I will bias toward taking paths
that have fewer edges, not just
smaller weight.
So that first idea doesn't work.
Idea-- add large
number to each edge.
This is bad.
Makes weights
non-negative, but does not
preserve shortest paths.
So this is not a
good idea-- bad idea.
Is there any way
you can think of
to modify the edge weights
in a graph in any way that
will preserve shortest paths?
So here is an idea
for you, which
is kind of this critical step in
Johnson's and in a lot of graph
transformation algorithms.
If I have a vertex, say
this middle guy, say v,
every path from v goes
through an outgoing edge of v.
And every path going into v goes
through an edge going into v.
I haven't said anything--
I've said very stupid things.
But that observation
is critical here.
If I add a number--
or let me see if I got
this right in terms
of adding and subtracting.
If I add a number to all
outgoing edges from a vertex,
and I subtract that same
number from the weights of all
of the incoming edges to that
vertex, then every path from v
is changed by the same amount,
because every path from v
goes through one of
those outgoing edges.
And any path going
into v has also
changed by the same amount.
In particular, it's changed
by a negative, whatever
we added to the outgoing edges.
So such a transformation,
adding a number
from all the outgoing
edges from a vertex
and subtracting that same number
from all the incoming edges,
preserves shortest paths.
That's a claim.
Idea-- this is a better idea.
Given vertex v, add--
I'm going to put
this on two lines.
Add weight h to
all outgoing edges,
and subtract weight
to all incoming edges.
So that's the idea.
And the claim is,
this transformation,
shortest paths are preserved
under this transformation.
And why is that?
It's kind of the exact same
argument that I had over there.
Proof-- consider any path in
my graph, either if the path--
path could go
through v many times,
or it could go
through not at all.
If my path, if I have a
path, in my original graph G,
then with path weight w of pi--
this is my path--
it goes through v
some number of times.
So I'm going to say this
is going from s to t.
If it crosses v-- if
it never crosses v,
if it never touches v, the
vertex that I transformed,
then I argue that the
path weight is the same
because I didn't do anything
to edges that are in this path.
Alternatively, this thing
goes through v sometimes.
If it goes through
v in the middle,
how is the weight
of my path changed?
Well, it hasn't, because I added
a number to all outgoing edges,
so there's an outgoing
edge here with weight
I've changed by weight h.
And there's an
incoming edge here
that I've changed by
weight negative h.
So these cancel out
and you've got 0.
So passing through
a vertex doesn't
change the weight of my path.
The only way I could change
the weight of my path
is if v is the start
vertex or the end vertex.
So it's possible that s is
my vertex or t is my vertex.
Well, for any path
leaving v, I will
have increased the
weight of that path
by h, because I added a weight
h to all outgoing edges.
So again, while
the path weight has
changed, since all of
the paths leaving v
have changed by the same
amount, a shortest path
will still be a shortest path.
And same goes for t.
If t, the end vertex is
v, I'll have subtracted h
from all of my
incoming edges, which
means that any path ending at t,
any directed path ending at t,
also changes by the same value.
And so shortest paths
must be preserved.
So shortest paths preserved.
So that's pretty
cool transformation.
I can assign for any vertex
such a transformation which
affects all of the
edges surrounding it
by this h additive factor,
either added or subtracted.
So maybe-- and I can do this
independently for every vertex.
The shortest paths
were preserved
by me doing this to one vertex.
Then if I do it
to another vertex,
then shortest paths
are still preserved.
And let's prove that real quick.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to want to do this to
give me flexibility
for changing all the
edge weights in my graph
to have this property.
I'm going to set--
or define a potential function h
that maps vertices to integers.
So this is the potential
h of v. And then we're
going to make a graph, G prime
based on above transformation
for each vertex in v.
So I'm going to set a
number, an h for each vertex.
These are independent now.
And I'm going to
add that potential
to all outgoing edges.
And I'm going to
subtract that potential
from all incoming edges.
This transformation is going
to preserve shortest paths.
Let's actually be a
little bit more rigorous
that that's the case when
we do this multiple times.
So claim-- shortest paths
are still preserved.
All right, well, that's,
again, not so difficult to see.
Let's consider a
path from s to t.
It passes through a
bunch of vertices.
I'm going to label these
as v0 to vk so that I can
kind of number them.
All right, this is v1 here.
This is a directed path, v1,
2, 3, 4, all the way up to k.
There are k edges in this graph.
I claim to you that any path
from v0 to vk, any shortest
path from v0 to vk remains a
shortest path after I reweight
everything in this way.
So let's say this is path
pi, and so it has weight w
pi, which is really just
the sum of all of the edge
weights from vi minus 1 to
vi, for i equals 1 to k.
This is poor notation.
This is the weight of the
edge from the vi minus 1 to i.
And we've got-- it
indexes from 1--
that's the first edge--
to k, which is the last edge.
So that's the weight of my path.
The weight of my
transformed path--
I'm going to do it down here.
It's a little iffy.
The weight of my transformed
path I'm going to say
is the weight in this new
weighted graph G prime.
This weight of that same path--
it's the same path--
is just going to be the sum of
all of the reweighted edges.
So i equals 1 to k of my
original weight of my edge,
so from 0, i minus 1 to vi.
But what did I do?
This edge is outgoing
from vi minus 1.
So it's outgoing, so
I add that weight--
that potential, sorry.
But that edge is also
incoming into vi.
So when I reweighted the thing,
I got a subtraction of h, vi.
Now, what happens
here in the sum,
this term, if I just took
the sum over this term,
that's exactly my
original pathway.
So that's good.
But you'll notice that
this sum has k terms,
and this sum has the
subtraction of k other terms.
But most of these
terms are equal.
Along the path, all the incoming
and outgoing edges cancel out.
So we're left with only
adding the potential
at the starting vertex and
subtracting the potential
at the final vertex.
So we've got, add
h, v0 minus h, vk.
And why is that good?
Well, that's good because
every path from v0
to vk starts at
v0 and ends at vk.
That's just-- that's how it is.
That's how we've defined
paths going from v0 to vk.
But every such path,
we transform the weight
of that path by adding
a constant associated
with the start and adding this
value associated with the end.
And so every path going
from v0 to vk changes
by the same amount.
And so if this path
pi was shortest,
it's still shortest in
the reweighted graph
because I've just changed
all paths between those two
vertices by the same amount.
This is kind of like a
telescoping argument here
in that kind of proof.
Right.
So we have, the weight changes.
It could change, but it changes
all paths between these two
vertices by the
same amount, which
means that shortest
paths are still shortest.
Awesome.
OK, so the name of
the game here is now,
we have this really
flexible tool.
We have this tool where we
can add or subtract weight
from various edges.
But we have to do so in a kind
of localized, constrained way.
We have to do the same
thing around each vertex.
But it seems like a powerful
transformation technique
that maybe we can get
this thing that we want,
which is a G prime, a
reweighting of the graph where
all the edge weights are
positive or non-negative.
So does there exist an h
such that the weights are all
positive?
What does that mean?
w prime u, v, the weight in
my new graph, in G prime,
I want these modified
weights, this modified
weight of my graph, I want each
of these to be non-negative.
So does there
exist such a thing?
Huh.
Well, if I rearrange this
equation a little bit,
this side, I get something
that looks like this.
h of v needs to be less
than or equal to h of u,
plus the weight of
some edge from u
to v. What does that look like?
That looks like almost
exactly the definition
of the triangle inequality.
Shortest path from some vertex
here and its shortest path
distance from the
same vertex here,
this is just a statement
of the triangle inequality.
So if we can set these h's
to be the shortest path
distance from some vertex and
those shortest path distances
are finite, and
not minus infinity,
then this thing will hold
by triangle inequality.
And in particular, if we were
to reweight the edges based
on those values of h,
then we get new edge rates
that are non-negative.
Awesome.
OK.
But there might
not be any vertex
from which we can access,
which we can reach
all vertices in the graph.
In particular, my graph
might not even be connected.
If I want this property,
I need all of these--
I don't gain any information
if these things are infinite.
It's exhaustively true.
Infinity is-- I
don't even know how
to compare infinity and
infinity plus a constant.
I don't know.
So I need all of these
things to be finite.
So how can I make
those things finite?
So here's the next idea.
Add new vertex s
with 0-weight edge
to every vertex, V in V.
We take our original graph.
We add a new super node
or auxiliary vertex
s, with a 0-weight edge to
every vertex in my graph.
What does that look like?
This is like-- there's
my original graph,
and now I have this vertex s.
But it has directed edges
into all of the vertices
with 0-weight.
That's our picture.
And this new thing I'm going
to call, maybe, my s graph now.
And the claim is, well now,
if I run some shortest path
algorithm, single
source shortest path
algorithm this time, from s
to compute the shortest path
distance to all of the
vertices, the shortest distance
to each of the vertices
can't be positive,
because there's a 0-weight edge.
So a minimum weight path is
going to be no bigger than 0.
If it's finite, then there's
a finite length shortest path.
If it's minus
infinity, then there's
a negative rate cycle in
my graph and I can stop.
So there are either
two situations.
If delta s,v equals
minus infinity--
so I guess this is, run single
source shortest paths from s.
And really, because this graph
could contain negative edge
weights and could
contain negative cycles,
we can't really do better
than running Bellman-Ford here
from s to compute these paths.
If there exists in this new
graph this Gs, if there exists
a vertex that has
negative infinite weight
in the reweighted graph--
sorry, in the original graph G--
G hasn't been reweighted yet.
If there's a negative
weight distance from s,
then there was a negative weight
cycle in the original graph.
Why is that?
Well, if this was set
to minus infinity,
then there is some negative
weight cycle in the graph.
The worry is that
that negative weight
cycle was added to my graph
by adding this vertex s.
But what do I know
about vertex s?
It has no incoming edges.
So no negative weight
cycle could go through s.
So any negative weight cycle
was in the original graph,
and so I can abort.
Abort.
Yay.
Otherwise, what do I do?
Well, I know the shortest
path distances here
would satisfy the
triangle inequality.
So if I reweight with h of
v equal to delta s of v,
if we set our potentials
in our reweighted graph
to be the shortest path
distance from our super node s,
it satisfies the
triangle inequality.
And because there's no negative
cycles, all of these values
are finite.
And then this reweighting will
lead to a graph with strictly--
or not strictly--
strictly no negative weights
or non-negative weights.
OK, great.
So that's basically it.
That's the idea behind
Johnson's algorithm.
It's really a reduction problem
or a reduction algorithm.
We reducing from solving
kind of signed all-pairs
shortest paths, graphs
where their weights could
be positive or
negative, and we're
reducing to creating
a graph that
has the same shortest
paths properties,
but only has non-negative
edge weights.
So we're reducing
from a signed context
to a non-negative
weight context.
So Johnson's algorithm,
what are the steps?
Construct Gs from
G, just as up here.
I make a new vertex s.
I put a 0 weight directed
edge from s to every vertex.
So that's the first step.
Second step-- compute E,
s,v for all V in V, i.e--
or e.g-- I guess
really it should
be i.e. because I don't really
have another option here--
but by Bellman-Ford.
This is just a single
run of Bellman-Ford here.
Compute.
And then there are
two possibilities.
If there exists a delta s,
v that's minus infinity,
then abort.
Else, make-- or reweight
the graph according to this
reweighting scheme, by
reweighting each edge
in my original graph
to have weight--
our new weight, which
is our old weight,
plus our transformation.
Now, our transformation is now
going to set h, v to this delta
s, v. So I'm going
to add delta s,
u, and subtract delta s, v.
That's our reweighting scheme.
I'm just identifying h, v with
this shortest path distance
here.
And after I reweighted
that, I can just
solve all-pairs shortest paths
on G prime with Dijkstra.
And then compute G shortest path
distances from G prime shortest
path distances.
Compute these distances from the
other using this algorithm up
here-- can compute distances
in G from distances in G prime
in linear time--
or sorry, v times linear
time, linear time for each s--
for each vertex in my graph.
OK, so that's the algorithm.
It's basically,
correctness is trivial.
We already proved-- the
whole part of this lecture,
the interesting
part of this lecture
was proving that, if we
had a transformation based
on a potential
function that changed
outgoing edges in a
symmetrically opposite way
as incoming edges, then that
preserves shortest paths.
And then realizing that the
triangle inequality enforces
this condition that
edge weights will
be non-negative under
this reweighting,
so we find shortest
path distances
from some other
arbitrary vertex,
and set our potential functions
to be those shortest path
distance weights.
We do the reweighting,
because that reweighting
preserves shortest paths,
which we already argued.
Then we can do-- then this
has positive edge weights,
so Dijkstra applies.
And then computing this
takes a small amount of time.
OK, what is the running
time of this algorithm?
So this part,
reconstructing this thing,
this takes linear time.
I'm just adding.
I'm just making a new
graph of the same size,
except I added v
edges and one vertex.
Computing-- doing Bellman-Ford
on this new modified graph,
that's just--
I'm doing that once.
That takes V times E time.
Doing this check,
that just takes--
I'm looping over my vertices.
That just takes V time.
Otherwise, doing
this reweighting,
I change the weight
of every edge.
That takes order E time.
And then solving G prime--
solving all-pairs shortest paths
on the modified edge weight
graph with Dijkstra
takes V times Dijkstra.
That's-- I could use a little
bit more board space here.
That's V times V
log, V plus E time,
which is actually the running
time that we're looking for.
I wanted to reduce to not
using more than this time.
We used this amount of time.
Let's make sure we still
didn't use even more.
After that, we compute these
paths, as proofed before,
in V times V plus E, which
is smaller than that.
And so summing up all
of these running times,
this one dominates.
And so Johnson's
can solve signed
weighted all-pairs
shortest paths, signed
all-pairs shortest paths, not
in V times Bellman-Ford, like we
had before up here,
but faster, in nearly
linear for sparse graphs,
just without this log factor.
So we got quite a
big improvement.
So that's the nice
thing about all-pairs
shortest paths is
that, really, we
don't have to incur this
big cost in the context
of negative weights.
Essentially, we just
run Bellman-Ford once
to see if there is a negative
weight cycle in my graph.
If it is, I save a lot of
work by stopping early.
So that's Johnson's.
That's the end of
our graphs lectures.
We'll be having a
review and problem
session about how to solve
problems, graph problems using
this material.
But we've talked about a lot
of different things so far.
We've talked about
graph reachability,
connected components,
detecting cycles, detecting
topological sort
orders of a DAG.
We've talked about finding
negative weight cycles,
single source shortest
path algorithms,
and now finally, today,
all-pairs shortest path
algorithms, with a new
algorithm that's really
not an entirely new algorithm.
We didn't have to do any
proof by induction here.
Really, the heavy
work that's happening
is we're reducing to using
either Dijkstra or Bellman-Ford
to do the heavy lifting of
finding single source shortest
paths efficiently.
So Johnson's is really
just glue to transform
a graph in a clever
way, and then
reducing to using some of
the shortest paths algorithms
faster.
So that's our unit on graphs.
Our next lecture,
we'll start talking
about a general form
of, not presenting you
with an algorithm,
but how to design
your own algorithm in the
context of dynamic programming.
So see you next lecture.